welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and she-hulk has been holding it down
as mcu earth's only clean green fighting
machine ever since smart hull decided to
leave earth yet again to seemingly go
take care of some stuff on sakaar in the
very same sakaran ship that caused him
and his cousin to mix family blood
together in a much less creepier way
than game of thrones they do that
differently but though bruce may have
left earth as smart hulk there's
actually a big chance that he returns to
earth as an old fart hulk after visiting
us a car where everyone that the hulk
met during those two years on sakhar has
been killed by the greatest menace known
to mortal beings of the mcu a little
thing called time let's get into it my
nerd babies because the sakaar that
bruce went to is going to look
completely different than the sakaar
that bruce abandoned for the devil's
anus but before we talk about that make
sure you head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
newest latest obsession shirt inspired
by she-hulk and house of the dragon
those are two amazing shirts that will
give you the ability to unlock shout
outs that will appear on our after shows
for those programs so check that out
today at new rockstarsmerch.com or any
of our other amazing merch on that
website but alright guys so like i said
before everybody that appeared in thor
ragnarok on the planet's a car that
isn't being played by one jeffrey
goldblum is very much very likely six
feet under all of that zakar and trash
and they actually very much died a super
long time ago primarily because of the
really weird nature of sakaar itself
because as we can see from the very
beginning of ragnarok when ella is
chasing her annoying little brothers in
the bifrost after loki gets knocked out
of set by frost and falls into a
wormhole into the car he tells thor they
spent the last few weeks getting in
grand master goldblum's good graces and
climbing up the sikaran social hierarchy
despite thor only being a mere few
seconds behind him for us about me weeks
ago weeks ago yes i just got here why
are you whispering
time works real different around these
parts on any other world i'd be like uh
millions of years old but here on sakai
like time is all sorts of messed up on
the grand masters planet of zakar
because time moves at an unusually fast
rate in comparison to the rest of the
universe in a very similar way to how
time works differently in the tba as
mobius and mobius establishes in the
loki series about loki and his
girlfriend loki just real quick this
video is brought to you by the ridge the
ridge wallet is like sleek and
industrial it's designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky back
pocket wallets that we won't talk about
here because this is a ridge wallet zone
it holds up to 12 cards and still has
room for cash the ridge wallet comes in
over 30 styles and colors including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium that's
how i like my titanium burnt there's
even an 18 karat gold plated wallet if
you're balling like that which i think
aisha and the other shiny sovereign
folks from guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 would appreciate because they
all about that gold life they they be
golden 24 7. and every ridge wallet
comes with a lifetime guarantee and
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it but that's highly
improbable because they make the best
wallets and it's got thirty thousand
five star reviews um they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries and they have
a cool event going on now where every
dollar spent on the website before
september 18th enters you to win a 2020
jeep gladiator or 50 000 if you prefer
cash and are really excited to paint
yourself gold to match your new ridge
wallet because that's what you do but
you know just don't affect yourself with
chemicals right
so get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge
r-i-d-g-e dot com slash new rockstars
and use the code new rockstars and you
can find the link in the video
description below of course it all has
to do with gravity because i'm not sure
if you noticed but the car is literally
covered in a ridiculous amount of
wormholes that do nothing but pour trash
and people onto the surface of the
planet to either be eaten or used and
this is a major sign that the gravity of
sakhar is completely out of whack
because scientifically speaking for a
planet to have this many weird portals
about there has to be an outrageous
amount of gravitational shenanigans
taking place especially when you have a
big-ass einstein-rosen bridge as huge
and gnarly as the devil's anus is
hovering over the face of sakhar i don't
want that type of anus over my face an
einstein rosenbridge is just a fancy way
for nerds to say wormhole by the way and
it's named that because of einstein's
theory of general relativity which
basically states that our perception of
space-time is heavily influenced by the
massiveness of the object that we're on
or in this instance a planet so
basically what i'm saying is sakhar's
gravity is really weird because sakhar
is a thick [ __ ] of a planet and the
entire planet is one big gravitational
anomaly and since gravity is messed up
time works differently for everyone on
the surface in comparison to everything
else not on the planet like everything
else in the universe but all of that
weird gravity gobbledygook being said
basically when hulk was on sakaar for
those two years because the mass of
sakhar is significantly different than
that of earth's the incredible hulk
spent much more than two years fighting
for the grand master which could partly
explain why the grandmaster feels a
special connection to him because this
is one of the few people on the sakaar
that doesn't die as fast as the grand
master because in the comics the grand
master is an elder of the universe who
has a super long life so if seconds for
thor were weeks for loki then hulk could
have taken over bruce's body for
centuries theoretically which would
definitely serve to explain hulk's
ability to speak in thor ragnarok
compared to age of ultron his new
personality that he developed and his
deep unwillingness to leave the planet
with thor when thor asked him to return
to earth because for hulk zakar is even
more of a home than earth ever was and
banner only really let hulk out to use
him when there was trouble afoot but
essentially bruce banner has lived a lot
longer in the universe than even his
best friend steve rogers has he was just
asleep for an extremely long time while
hulk was fighting all of his new friends
and enemies in the coliseum but anyways
here's the deal it's been about six to
seven earth years since bruce took hulk
off of the planet of sakhar and for
ragnarok which means that literally
everyone that hulk came across on sakhar
that isn't an elder of the universe is
deader than bruce banner's sex life i
can't get too excited
not even
and smart hulk is actually headed
towards a car that has advanced
potentially countless generations since
his last visit like sakhar is going to
look completely differently hopefully
less trash looking but this also means
that if smart hulk were to get stuck on
sakhar again for some reason during his
second trip back then the hulk that
comes back to meet his cousin will very
likely be extremely older than he was
before with an extraordinary amount of
stories to tell with all of those years
on sakhar and who knows maybe smart hulk
found out that he actually left behind a
baby on sakaar that is now a full-grown
man and smart hulk decides to stay in
sakaar to help raise this kid because we
know that the marvel character scar is
one such child with sicarian origins but
either way the next time that we see
bruce banner because of the
gravitational anomaly of the
grandmaster's planet zakar he's going to
be a super old hulk who might just have
a completely different personality than
bruce had before because of all those
years that he spent on sakhar and i for
one would love if marvel took the
opportunity to have bruce return to
earth as a bearded maestro version for a
future imperfect or world war hulk
scenario in the future but we shall see
my nerd babies we shall see i'm just a
soccer for world war hulk and i'm a big
fan of the maestro so let's get it come
on but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mastertainment on twitter if you
guys want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] and really fun and insane theories
but more importantly you follow new rock
charts wherever we are on the socials
and if you do on youtube make sure you
hit that notification so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video which is pretty much every day and
also do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerge.com so you can look flyer
than anybody that you know with our new
nerd gear especially the ones inspired
by she-hulk and house of the dragon but
again thank you so much for spending
time with me and i'll see you guys next
time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]